james wan's malignant is out in theaters
and on hbo max and everyone agrees the
ending is bonkers the movie's
mind-blowing third act leaves the
characters just as stunned as the
audience if you couldn't wrap your brain
around the final twists here's the
ending of malignant explained malignant
starts by introducing a malicious person
or entity named gabriel confined in a
research hospital in 1993 it then leaps
forward decades to pick up the story of
madison which appears to be completely
unrelated at least at first then we
learned that the connection between
gabriel and madison goes deeper than we
ever could have guessed after spending
most of the film under the impression
that gabriel was either psychically
connected to madison or possibly even a
supernatural entity that only she could
see the ending of malignant reveals the
shocking truth gabriel is actually
madison's parasitic twin who was born
attached to the back of her body madison
named emily for the first few years of
her life partially absorbed the
underdeveloped gabriel in their mother's
womb however they were born with both
twins conscious even though gabriel did
not have a usable body of his own though
madison and gabriel shared a brain they
used it very differently their
consciousnesses were mostly separate and
the malevolent gabriel would attempt to
manipulate madison to try to convince
her to carry out malicious acts after
being turned over to a research hospital
by their teenage mother the decision was
eventually made to surgically remove
gabriel from madison once the doctors
determined he could not be rehabilitated
however although they removed gabriel's
body they had to leave the brain intact
that part of gabriel remained mostly
dormant until he was reawakened many
years later
is a person like gabriel actually
possible the short answer is technically
yes but mostly no while craniopagus
parasiticus is a real condition in which
an underdeveloped parasitic twin is
attached by the head to a developed twin
the underdeveloped twin has never been
known to be conscious the condition is
extremely rare with only four to six
cases occurring every 10 million births
leaving only a very small sampling
throughout history to draw conclusions
from additionally although there have
been several attempts in the 21st
century to surgically remove the
parasitic twin in these cases those
children have never lived for very long
with the most successful procedure still
only extending the developed twins life
for another year so the odds of madison
being able to survive with gabriel until
the age of seven and then continued to
survive with no complications into
adulthood or minuscule at best the
chances of gabriel being able to take
over madison's body go on a killing
spree and beat an entire police station
in hand-to-hand combat are
even smaller
gabriel has the ability to manipulate
and control electricity and to use
electronic speakers to protect his voice
even when he physically couldn't speak
he also possesses superhuman strength
how he got those powers is never
explained although it's possible that
it's based on the myth that humans could
develop superpowers if we were able to
access 100 of our brain function rather
than the purported 10 that most humans
actually use what gabriel access in one
part of the brain and madison accessing
the rest maybe that heightened brain
function is supposed to be what gives
him his extraordinary abilities however
although it presents a cool premise for
movies the 100 brain myth has been
thoroughly debunked the truth is we
already do use pretty much all of our
brains leaving pretty much zero untapped
potential for superpowers but
considering the rest of malignant we
doubt that the film is particularly
concerned with real science making
gabriel's enhanced use of madison's
brain the most likely explanation for
what he can do although dr weaver hoped
that the surgery to remove gabriel's
body from madison's when she was a child
would banish his evil consciousness
forever that didn't turn out to be the
case madison continued to hear gabriel's
voice even after being adopted by her
new family when her adopted mother
became pregnant gabriel felt threatened
by the new baby worrying that if madison
had a new sibling she would no longer
need him so he manipulated madison
trying to convince her to kill her baby
sister however madison was able to
resist him in order to keep the baby
safe as madison's bond with her sister
sydney grew stronger she was able to
finally suppress gabriel banishing him
to the back corners of her mind and
snuffing out her memories of him this
enabled madison to have a mostly normal
life strengthened by her strong ties to
her family to subconsciously keep
gabriel mostly at bay at the beginning
of malignant a pregnant madison is
experiencing abdominal pain and worries
that something may be wrong with the
baby
through a conversation with her husband
derek we learned that this isn't
madison's first pregnancy but all of her
prior pregnancies have ended in
miscarriage the two fights and derek
throws madison against the wall hitting
the back of her head we later learned
that the cause of madison's miscarriages
was actually gabriel feeding off her
babies to gain strength when madison's
head hits the wall the impact is enough
to finally jostle gabriel back to full
consciousness once he's awake he
immediately begins executing his plan to
exact revenge on everyone he believes
has wronged him in madison beginning
with derek after killing derek he then
moves on to the doctors who removed his
body from madison's at the research
facility intending for his plan to
culminate in the deaths of his birth
mother in madison's adopted family
for most of malignant it appears as
though madison is nowhere near gabriel's
murders as he commits them she believes
she is receiving psychic visions of
gabriel's attacks which allow her to
watch what is happening but not
intervene
did you know her
no
but i saw her die
but in the final act of the film the
horrifying truth is revealed gabriel is
actually using madison's body to carry
out his attacks whenever gabriel takes
over her body he also takes over her
brain giving her the illusion of being
in a separate location the whole time in
reality madison is always physically
present at the murders but unconscious
with her mind being manipulated by
gabriel to keep her from understanding
how he's using her body
when detective shaw and regina moss
finally can't ignore the growing pile of
evidence that madison is at least
closely related to the recent string of
killings they bring her in for an
interrogation while madison is insisting
on her innocence shaw's phone rings with
a call from an unknown number shaw puts
a call on speaker and it's gabriel's
voice speaking to the detectives while
madison sits wordlessly across from them
that's him
he wants to talk to you
it seems to prove that gabriel and
madison can't be the same person but
he's actually cleverly using his
extraordinary abilities to throw them
off the track through his manipulation
of electricity he's able to control
shaw's phone and then he uses the
speaker to create his voice as we've
seen him do many times before it's an
ingenious way to attempt to prove
madison's innocence but unfortunately
the detectives still don't trust her
enough to release her instead they put
her in a holding cell with a number of
other women which proves to be a grave
mistake
at the end of malignant it appears that
gabriel has finally won overpowering
madison once and for all to kill both
madison's sister and mother in the
hospital but it quickly becomes clear
that madison has turned gabriel's own
tricks against him just as he had
tricked her into thinking she was safe
at home when her body was in a totally
different part of town committing
gruesome murders madison tricked him
into believing he was killing sydney and
his mother in reality she had finally
gained the mental strength to take back
control of her body she then confronted
gabriel inside her mind locking him in a
mental cage so he couldn't control her
anymore unfortunately the problem that
existed at the beginning of malignant
still remains since gabriel and madison
share a brain there is no way to
completely remove gabriel without
killing madison therefore although
madison can't trap him she can't get rid
of him entirely he's always there
occupying some part of her brain she
even acknowledges this in the end when
gabriel taunts her that she won't be
able to keep him locked up forever
however this time madison is an adult
not a child and has no intention of
burying what she knows deep in her
subconscious again this time she tells
gabriel she will be ready for him when
he inevitably eventually breaks out of
course it's also highly likely that
she'll be doing that from the inside of
a prison cell since even though we all
know that mentally she was innocent of
gabriel's murders the police aren't
likely to let her physical body off the
hook check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite horror movies are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]